all right first of all one of the great
movies of all time
loved it when it came out but no no this
is ridiculous
hi my name is chris whitcomb i'm a
former fbi agent
i was a member of the hostage rescue
team been involved in dozens of high
profile operations around the world
including the siege at ruby ridge idaho
and at waco texas
and today i'll be rating hostage rescue
scenes and movies
you want a bullet in your head
we do have to repel from time to time
from above
down to the hostages to effect a rescue
in this case they use a technique of
australia we used to call it australian
repelling oftentimes we'd use
a breach we'd lower down an explosive
device below or something of that nature
but in this case they go face first the
belay device
is behind you and you would use a hand
behind your back
so that you could face down and it
probably works better in this type of
the situation
anytime you have people gathered in one
area you can have hostages so we have to
prepare for all those things
you could have a plane you could have a
high-rise building you could have any of
those things
a ship underway at sea has got to be one
of the most difficult so we practice
hostage rescue on ships yes you've got
to get there to begin with
which is a helicopter operation you've
got to have some kind of stealth
which means night vision you're probably
above where they're keeping the hostages
and then you have to get down to them so
that would entail fighting your way down
stairwells
you could go down the outside of the
ship and go in from the outside
on my mark
anytime you have a hostage rescue
operation
you've got a lot of moving pieces you
have to make sure they all go at the
same time
you want to go in with speed surprise
and violence of action
the sniper shots then the door breach
and then the entry by the assaulters so
that's quite realistic
if you can get into a space without
sending people inside that's ideal
so in this case snipers executed what we
call an open air option
which you send bullets into the space
not human beings
and that was very well done in the scene
shooting is a very very important part
of this job but it's only one
element of the job the coordination is
very very important so we would practice
that
day after day after day if you're a
sniper you shoot at
various distances but you practice that
coordinated shot
and it's almost like being a drummer in
a band where you just get used to the
rhythm in a training environment you
would hear ready
ready ready ready aim fire
and you have to shoot on that cadence so
it is very important
that the sniper shots go together well
look it's it's a superhero movie right
and it's a
it's entertainment but i think they got
a lot of things right i'd have to give
it a 7.
i need eyes on sir they're going to
shoot him
execute
it's difficult to convey how difficult
this job is
you have an unstable platform shooting
off a ship
at another unstable platform another
ship at night
through a tiny tiny opening
in that lifeboat that small window
things happen so quickly and there is no
room for error
it's an incredibly difficult shot and
that's pretty accurate the way it
happens you get a very very small window
and the consequences of life and death
you hear a lot about sniper pairs the
hostage rescue team when i was there we
would
operate in pairs but not because one was
an observer and one was a shooter
it's just so one can be on a scope and
ready to shoot so the other can rest
often times it is just because the
ability to take a shot can erode very
very quickly and you have to be fresh
when you
when you need to take the shot if the
shot needs to be taken it's usually
because the situation has eroded
quickly and so badly that you have no
other option
um look this is based on a real life
event it was
entertainment and built up a little bit
but based on actual events so i've got
to give it a 9.
now that sucker
all right first of all one of the great
movies of all time loved it when it came
out
but no now this is ridiculous
hostage rescue is a very carefully
coordinated
high risk operation we did occasionally
look at the possibility of shooting from
a helicopter i've got a photograph of me
doing just that
the problem is you wouldn't fire an
automatic weapon from a helicopter
certainly not with civilians standing
around if anybody
fired it would not be suppressive fire
it would be a sniper shot
the first thing i think people need to
understand is the hostage rescue
is very very highly refined they are
hostage negotiators
they have intelligence gathering
mechanisms and the last resort is the
application of the hostage rescue team
very rarely would you ever see a rapid
action like depicted in this movie
they're very very carefully coordinated
and they work
with precision none of those things you
see in this movie
i've got to rate the movie as a 10 great
entertainment but as a depiction of a
hostage rescue i'd give it a
one where's jerry jeremy watch your
stairs x-rays may escape down they'll be
shooting so what's your art
what's interesting when this happened i
was going to school i was in college
in london and i lived just around the
corner i was there and watched the
watch the raid the one really great
thing about this movie and showing the
history of this art form
is the what we call a kill house a
shooting house
various names but you have to practice
going into a space
shooting live ammunition door breaches
in low light conditions with all kinds
of terrible things going on
explosions people screaming smoke
everything
and they would create an indoor space
practice over and over and over again
going
through that space and it makes the odds
of success that much better you want a
familiar environment
and that's what you're seeing here
things always go wrong no matter how
much you practice no matter how good you
are
things always go wrong guys get hung up
and ropes break and explosives go off or
they don't go off you have to make
alternate breaches and i think the movie
depicted pretty well what went wrong
and and how they rolled with that and
how fluid
a hostage rescue can be because you
can't stop and
and do it over again once you roll it's
on oftentimes you'll have a
an initial breach point but you'll have
alternate breach points as well
you'll have alternate planes people get
shot people go down
you have medical emergencies you have a
million different things that can go
wrong
so you have to improvise adapt overcome
we always used to say you could teach
anybody to shoot
you can get anybody physically fit it's
knowing when
and how to pull a trigger it's knowing
when and how to come up with a backup
plan
those things are really important and
that happened to princess gate and it's
depicted well in this movie
the sas went in and some of the hostage
takers tried to sneak out with the
hostages
when you go in with a tactical element
for a hostage rescue operation
everybody goes to the floor you don't
know who's a bad guy
it's smoke it's violent it's chaos it is
absolute chaos except for the people
doing the rescue operation this was a
perfect place
where the british government realized
how difficult that could be
i think the most important thing to get
out of some of these movies is the
people
the operators that do this job they are
truly
remarkable these are people who
are more than willing to run in and die
if that's the case
but don't plan to i i love this movie i
thought they did a brilliant job i'd
rate it at 10.
fox the swats are targeting the wrong
people the clowns are lost
batman would help in any situation i
wish we had a batman right
some elements of this were really well
done repelling i guess was pretty
accurate the weapons looked pretty good
uh the tactics looked bad the lifeblood
of any operation like this
is intelligence you want information
accurate information
so if they being the command element
knew that hostages had weapons we didn't
know who was who
uh it would make it very very difficult
to send somebody in this is a good
example of
when you don't go in when you go into a
building like this
as i said before you have to make sure
everybody is secure because you don't
know who's good and who's bad in all
circumstances
if somebody's shooting at you obviously
you're going to shoot them
if they have a weapon and you can take
them to the ground that might be a
better option
some things are well done and plausible
but it's listen it's a
it's a superhero movie i i don't know
maybe a seven
got an easy shot please advise standby
roger
things go wrong i one time was on an
operation
and uh we had this very very very
sensitive insertion we couldn't get
busted under any circumstances one of
the guys
in my sniper cadre crawled up in a
ground hornet's nest
and just gets hammered in what might be
a life-threatening situation
never made a sound didn't flinch and had
to exfil for medical treatment
so things do go wrong but you have to
eat them
there's no training for that you you've
got to remember that these guys are
incredibly disciplined a rat's not going
to bother anybody no
tubular targets are difficult they're
oftentimes moving you get a car
a bus a plane a train a subway car
and even if he hadn't responded to that
rat and had taken a stable shot
a bullet going through a medium like
glass can do a million different things
so you have to practice that too not
just the shot but what the bullet's
going to do
in so many different circumstances you
don't want to shoot through a target
put somebody else in on the other side
in danger obviously
but one thing that's really important to
remember is that you always have a
backup plan so if you have a sniper shot
it is going to be followed up with an
assault component as well
and if that assault component is ready
to go they would have stormed the train
immediately and resolved it in a
different way so
the planning and the execution of this
raid would not have gone this way
because we would have some immediate
action
an emergency assault if necessary had a
shotgun wrong for whatever reason
and i think the scene makes sense in a
lot of different ways a rat crawling up
a sniper's leg is not going to have this
impact
no
well i'm going to say i'm kind of
partial this movie first of all the
director peter berg
is a very good friend of mine for 35
years or something like that he put me
in the movie kind of the cameo thing
like play the
commander of that hostage rescue team
component right there
he's putting on a door breach right now
and this is a slap charge which is
basically a piece of rubber with some
plastic explosive
you have the overall hostage rescue team
then you have smaller components
at that time the teams were about seven
men on a team
and that's what you see
anybody can blow open a door you want to
blow open the door so it doesn't bounce
off the backstop so there's an art to
the
explosive breaching in these enterprises
and that's what we're showing right here
hrt went up to try and assist uh
everybody in the boston operation
and when they got there the there were
so many cops and so many people involved
they couldn't
get any rent-a-cars so they flew up and
they had to rent minivans
so the hrt operation for the boston
marathon bombing
that you see depicted in the movie the
guys actually arrived in minivans
so uh you you do what you have to do
from time to time
i just want to point out the weapons you
use in these type of situations i always
looked at guns as tools
carpenter can't build a house with a
screwdriver so you have different
weapons and what you see right here
is a typical assault rifle so i
personally had 17 different weapons
for different situations everything from
a 50 caliber
long gun for sniper applications to
something like this
this is a this might be used as a door
breach it's not your primary weapon
but you might need to go to it so your
primary weapon might be something small
and compact like this
uh if that weapon goes down for whatever
reason you could go with a backup weapon
which would be some
handgun this is a nine millimeter which
oftentimes we would use
in a case like this you might carry
three or four different weapons what you
use for weapons
really can make a difference especially
in closed spaces like this
well obviously i'm prejudiced but pete
berg did a brilliant job here
and although a very very simple
operation this is the way it would go
down in real life the way it did go down
in real life so
uh i've got to give it a 10. got it
she'll miss what's the probability of
that
based on the temperature and humidity no
wind half moon good light
97.6 a shot from any gun
is simple physics you got a pellet going
through the air it's pulled out by
gravity
and it's impacted in its trajectory a
short shot
has fewer variables a long shot has
greater variables
in this case you're talking about a
handgun at what maybe 20 feet something
like that humidity
uh light all of those things are not
going to have much of an impact a longer
shot it's going to have a huge impact
move or i'll do it take it
baby sniper on hit one time took a shot
at a guy
who had a child taped to his back and
had a woman in front of him with a
shotgun to her head
so the child's head i think was almost
touching his and an hrt
sniper had to take that shot moving from
left to right
it is difficult to explain to people
how difficult it is to shoot another
human being
under all the various circumstances i'm
just going to say
that it is plausible the dialogue was
reasonably well done there are things
that i would have thought about so
i'd probably give it an 8 i think
i don't know what that building is that
wasn't at ruby ridge i don't know what
that is
place we'll have the gold team backing
up the blue team position
it's infuriating to me i was one of
those guys there were seven of us not a
room full of us
we were standing in ghillie suits and
the pouring rain it was 32 degrees or
something like that the rules of
engagement were a little bit different i
testified before the senate
we've had all kinds of investigations
over the years and we were going up
under
totally different circumstances so
there's nothing even remotely realistic
about what you just saw
if they're out there i guess they don't
want to talk
well there were seven of us up there on
that hill i was lying behind a sniper
rifle had the whole thing in my scope i
watched everything
from beginning to end and i can tell you
that is the most
ridiculous false representation of what
happened i could possibly state
the fact that a a sniper would be
standing up behind a tree which is
absurd the only thing that's accurate
about that entire clip long horizon's
shot
did go through the door the pane of
glass in the door threw a curtain
and the door looked similar to that door
so the curtain and the door look similar
the circumstances are not remotely
accurate they didn't come up and have a
conversation standing on a rock
uh none of that happened it is complete
and utter fiction
bottom line is we were at a holding area
in a valley down below the ridge
we land navigated our way up through
appalling weather conditions
and we set up a perimeter uh part a
partial perimeter on the cabin
and i had just laid down behind my
sniper rifle and i was just trying to
get an idea of what was going on and our
job was to send
information back to the command
development because we didn't know what
was going on up there
it happened very very quickly way below
zero
it's just it makes me so angry to think
that people would watch that and think
that happened it's
absurd the siege is over now
the gas you will be spelling is a
non-lethal tear gas
i was i think one of the first two or
three people that arrived at waco
the only thing about this movie i like
is it's incredible how accurately they
recreated that building
i mean absolutely unbelievable so i'm
not going to talk about what they did
right and what they did wrong
i'm going to say that it was a very very
violent resolution and
it went terribly wrong for all parties
involved
in this particular case they sent us in
to try
and get the kids out we considered the
children and the unwilling
branch davidians inside the building as
hostages and our job was to get them out
alive
we thought it would have made great
sense if we'd gone in that night
doing what we as a hostage rescue team
did very very well
and we thought we could have saved
everybody they'd been in a fire fight
they were wounded
they were on their heels we thought we
could have resolved it that did not
happen
what happened is we put a fence around
the place essentially
and waited until that last day when the
attorney general decided to send us in
by that time the odds were so heavily
stacked against us
i don't i don't know that anybody ever
really thought we had much of a chance
but obviously didn't go well then either
once washington dc made the decision to
go in the plan was
to insert a chemical irritant
tear gas for lack of a better term into
the building so we had
what looked like tanks they were tanks
that had nozzles on the front in order
to get the gas in the building
you have to inject it in the building so
the tanks drove up
injected gas into the building so we
went with armored vehicles
inserted the gas tore some of the walls
opened
to allow people to get out and it went
precipitously downhill from there
and i think this was a horrible
misrepresentation of what happened
it may have represented what the
negotiators did but it had
little to do with the reality of what i
experienced when i was there and i
thought it was appallingly bad
ultimately we want to save people's
lives and
this movie did not accurately depict
that in any way
well it's a personal thing for me but i
would rate it zero i i
i i i it makes me ill pasta rescue's not
really
just guys going in through doors with
machine guns and black outfits on it's
really about
an entire process and the end result
when nothing else works
is to send people through a door breach
you want to avoid that if possible if
you need to do that
you need to be prepared and understand
the consequences